(heavy piano music)
♪ Kevin ♪
♪ Where's my pen, blud ♪
(hiphop beat begins)
♪ D'ya remember? ♪
♪ Last year we would hang round ends ♪
♪ (Last year) ♪
♪ And you came up to me and you asked me ♪
♪ "Can I use your pen?" ♪
♪ I was, like, sure ♪
♪ (Course) ♪
♪ I've lent it out before ♪
♪ And I always got it back ♪
♪ But I ain't seen pen no more ♪
♪ (Ain't seen that pen) ♪
♪ Next time that I saw you ♪
♪ It was all kinds of awkward ♪
♪ I didn't wanna ask you straight out ♪
♪ Thought that'd be too forward ♪
♪ It'd been two weeks by then ♪
♪ What, you hope I'd forgot it ♪
♪ While you had hands on my Parker ♪
♪ Right there in your parka's pocket ♪
♪ A month's gone by and still
you ain't given it back ♪
♪ Now my anxiety's mounting ♪
♪ 'Cause that wasn't just some biro ♪
♪ Man, that ting was a fountain ♪
♪ Now you got me doubtin' ♪
♪ Like you're no longer mates with me ♪
♪ Just know you keep my stationery ♪
♪ I'll leave you stationary ♪
♪ Why'd you even need it, 'cause? ♪
♪ What you even signing ♪
♪ We've been friends since primary ♪
♪ And you can't do joined-up writing ♪
♪ I got that pen for my birthday ♪
♪ That's a rite of passage ♪
♪ And since my pen's been missing ♪
♪ I can't write a passage ♪
♪ (No) ♪
♪ I want my pen ♪
♪ I lent it to you ♪
♪ And now ain't seen it again ♪
♪ I want my pen ♪
♪ Gimme back my pen ♪
♪ Like a striker going down in the box ♪
♪ I want my pen ♪
♪ (Look) ♪
♪ It's been eight weeks at this point ♪
♪ This whole thing's affecting my life ♪
♪ I'm worrying that you broke it ♪
♪ And you won't make it write ♪
♪ And even if you gave it back ♪
♪ Even if it weren't deliberate ♪
♪ What if you've used up the cartridge ♪
♪ That's just ink-onsiderate ♪
♪ I'm spitting these bars off the dome ♪
♪ They're coming straight from the crown ♪
♪ That was the only pen that I owned ♪
♪ So I couldn't write my rhymes down ♪
♪ Think I'm overreacting ♪
♪ Like, "Why you gotta take this hard?" ♪
♪ We just had my grandma's 80th ♪
♪ And I couldn't even sign her card ♪
♪ (She's 80) ♪
♪ It was the ultimate pen ♪
♪ And I don't mean second to last ♪
♪ When I was bored in class ♪
♪ It got unscrewed and taken apart ♪
♪ Just bring it back, apologize ♪
♪ I'm sure we'll make amends ♪
♪ But if you chewed up the end ♪
♪ You'll get chewed up in the ends ♪
♪ D'your mum not teach you manners ♪
♪ Why all this impertinence? ♪
♪ You've got 10 days to return it, cuz ♪
♪ That's when things get turbulent ♪
♪ I'm talking Turkish ♪
♪ Chopped up like Saudi journalist ♪
♪ When I step to you with my Sharpie ♪
♪ Leaving a mark that's permanent ♪
♪ (Talking 'bout a knife) ♪
♪ 'Cause I want my pen ♪
♪ I lent it to you ♪
♪ And now ain't seen it again ♪
♪ I want my pen ♪
♪ Gimme back my pen ♪
♪ Like a homeless pig ♪
♪ (Oink) ♪
♪ I want my pen ♪
♪ You told me that you'd
give it back in a minute ♪
♪ Blud, it's been six months ♪
♪ This is why nobody likes you ♪
♪ This is why they call
you a (gunshot blasts) ♪
♪ Own up to your rudeness, wasteman ♪
♪ You got no balls like Ken ♪
♪ Next time that you borrow something ♪
♪ Give it right back like Trent ♪
♪ Should've never let you
have it in the first place ♪
♪ Never let you take it off of me ♪
♪ Should've stuck a pen in your windpipe ♪
♪ Amateur tracheotomy ♪
♪ Should've John Wick-ed you ♪
♪ Prick with a Bic ♪
♪ 'Til the blood in your neck drips out ♪
♪ Like a kid that chokes on a pen lid ♪
♪ You'll get capped in the mouth ♪
(gunshot blasts)
♪ No pen ♪
♪ Do penance ♪
♪ I'll make sure you are dead ♪
♪ (Dead) ♪
♪ You'll have red on you ♪
♪ Shaun of the Dead ♪
♪ You've had your final warning ♪
♪ So now I aim for the head ♪
♪ (Head) ♪
♪ And turn you into a pencil ♪
♪ Full of lead ♪
♪ Pen's mightier than the sword ♪
♪ Is it mightier than my nine? ♪
♪ Your life's like real neat writing ♪
♪ On the line ♪
♪ I'm coming round there
with a gat for a chat ♪
♪ And you know that
I'll take what's mine ♪
♪ Wait, hold up ♪
♪ It was behind my ear the whole time ♪
♪ (Oh, no way) ♪
♪ I got my pen ♪
♪ (Yeah) ♪
♪ I lent it to you ♪
♪ And now I've found it again ♪
♪ I got my pen ♪
♪ You clearly returned my pen ♪
♪ I got my pen back ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Amen ♪
♪ (Sorry I threatened
to kill you, Kevin) ♪